frenéticos encuentros diplomáticos para
desescalar la crisis entre rusia y
occidente en moscú el presidente
vladimir putin recibió a su homólogo
francés emmanuel marco durante más de
cinco horas sin resultados concretos
pero con la intención de seguir
dialogando y
construir juntos respetando nuestros
fundamentos garantías concretas de
seguridad para los estados miembros de
la unión europea para los estados de la
región
ucrania georgia belarús y para rusia es
exactamente la ambición que debemos
perseguir la ambición cuando hubo un
poco de acceso estarán en wii en lo que
a nosotros respecta haremos todo lo
posible para encontrar compromisos que
se adapten a todos en washington el
presidente estadounidense joe biden
recibió al canciller alemán olaf scholz
los mandatarios pusieron sobre la mesa
las posibles sanciones a rusia de
invadir ucrania y la casa blanca
endureció el tono sobre las
consecuencias sin contar con el visto
bueno alemán
efe
si rusia invade eso significa que
tanques o tropas crucen la frontera de
ucrania
entonces no habrá north stream 2
sin embargo scholz reiteró que la
cooperación entre los europeos y eeuu
prevalecerá esa pobreza como ya dije
estamos actuando juntos estamos
absolutamente unidos y no tomaremos
pasos diferentes daremos los mismos
pasos y serán muy duros contra rusia
esta escalada de tensiones ha sido
calificada por la otan como la peor
desde la guerra fría se dio por el
despliegue de tropas rusas en la
frontera con ucrania según la casa
blanca moscú ya habría concentrado más
de 100 mil tropas frente a su vecino
quien denuncia que rusia quiere invadir
el territorio ucraniano con el
antecedente de la anexión de la
península de crimea en 2014